el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se apresuró a felicitar al
presidente electo de eeuu joe biden y a
la vicepresidenta kamala harris en lo
que calificó como un logro histórico en
las recientes elecciones presidenciales
de eeuu a través de su cuenta oficial de
twitter
johnson recordó que eeuu es su aliado
más importante y señaló que espera
trabajar juntos en temas de interés
común como son el cambio climático el
comercio y la seguridad
johnson quien es cercano al actual
presidente de donald trump quien apoya
el break sheet le había prometido un
tratado comercial una vez que abandone
la unión europea sin embargo con la
llegada de joe biden a la casa blanca el
tratado comercial podría retrasarse y
aún no se sabe si el reino unido- estará
o no en su lista de prioridades
joe biden podría viajar aquí al reino
unido el próximo año para asistir a la
cumbre del cambio climático el próximo
noviembre y también a la cumbre del
grupo de los siete de las cuales boris
johnson
anfitrión además johnson podría ser uno
de los primeros mandatarios en volar a
washington si la epidemia del cob y te
lo permite para reunirse con joe biden
en 2021